Hilary Clinton and Donald Trump Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton Hillary Trump
and Donald Clinton no matter how you
rearrange their name something is really
really wrong with our political system
right now you know this to be true
whether you're a political junkie or if
you couldn't name the vice president if
your life depended on it
our broken system churning out
uninspiring candidates coupled with our
broken media that often just repeats
campaign talking points has given us two
broken candidates from two broken
parties competing in a broken election
for control of a nation going broke this
isn't how it was supposed to be nor is
it how it has to be I don't particularly
like Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump
Hillary has been involved in the
political machine for the past thirty
years at various levels from wife of a
governor to first lady to Senator to
Secretary of State and it's not really
clear to me of her accomplishments
outweigh her poor decisions nothing she
says strikes me as real or honest like
how she's constantly railing against
Wall Street while at the same time
taking at least 25 million dollars from
Wall Street this campaign cycle alone at
a time when we're all frustrated by the
system she is the ultimate insider
trying to maintain her grip on power and
her willful ineptitude at best or gross
negligence at worst with her emails her
questionable decisions in Iraq and Libya
and the Clinton Foundation's ties to
various foreign governments and there is
a lot of questions about her campaign
she also constantly plays into the
social justice and oppression Olympics
which judges us all as groups rather
than individuals and I'm pretty sure you
guys know how I feel about that as for
Trump even after all these months of
campaigning I still have no real idea
what he thinks about any issue he seems
to have a staggeringly low amount of
knowledge about basic policies or how
the government is designed to work
do you really think he knows the
different duties of the executive
legislative and judicial branches of
government the fact that I can't say so
for sure that he does is extremely
concerning to say least I also don't
sense he has any sort of moral Center
other than what's good for him at the
very moment he will say anything
quite literally anything to stay in the
news and we simply have no idea how he
would govern his comments constantly toe
the line between fact and fiction and he
seems deeply uninterested in other
opinions than his own while many think
he'll shatter the monster of political
correctness currently assaulting us it
seems like a tall order for someone who
threatens to ban news organizations and
sue reporters when they ask him hard
questions or challenge his statements so
how did we possibly get to a place where
everyone I talked to is either bruh
grudgingly voting for one of these two
people or just won't vote at all how did
we end up with two deeply unpopular
polarizing people who seemingly
represent the worst of us as the only
two legitimate candidates for the
highest office in the land it's probably
time we looked in the mirror and saw our
own responsibility in this unfolding
clown show the rioting has been on the
wall for years we watch garbage reality
shows some of them hosted by future
presidential candidates we read biased
listicles full of gifts instead of
actual news articles we say vicious
things to people online that we would
never say to their faces our thoughts
have been reduced to six second videos
140 character sentences filtered images
and mindless snaps we reward the
Kardashians with fame and fortune while
we can't come up with the money to take
care of our veterans we watch news
channels that are nothing but
mouthpieces for the political parties we
shame and slander and D platform people
we disagree with we issue trigger
warnings and safe spaces instead of
promoting true education and open
discussion we ask for better leaders but
then we don't vote
action day we complain but we don't get
involved when you step back and you
think about all of this it's pretty
obvious why we got left with these two
candidates now allow me to make the
quick case of why you should vote for
each one of these people in case you
didn't think I was going to do that with
Hillary you know what you're gonna get
our system is messed up but she's part
of it and she's damn well going to make
sure that the wheels don't come off
during her watch she's a known quantity
in that she cares about her legacy and
she doesn't want to see the country
crumble after spending her entire life
trying to get to this very place in
short if you think things are going okay
it makes sense to vote for Hillary the
case for Trump is totally the reverse
he's an unknown quantity and the system
hates in me he's given a voice to middle
America that is usually ignored or
mocked by an elite he represents the
greatest threat to this social justice
Fiasco infecting all levels of society
he's used the political system and our
pathetic media against itself in short
if you think that things are really
messed up and we have to change it at
any cost
then it absolutely makes sense to vote
for Trump I for one despite everything
I've said here think that the truth lies
somewhere in between there is no
question that our system is screwed up
but the truth is it's still one of the
best ones out there and despite our
flaws Americans have freedoms which make
people all over the world envious people
still look to America as a beacon of
light in the world people still want to
move here and most of us don't want to
move out we have an imperfect system but
a system that can and will survive these
two imperfect candidates some people are
voting for Hillary because they think
she's the last line of defense against
Trump who they likened to Hitler some
people are voting for Trump because they
think he's the only way to stop Hillary
The Manchurian Candidate what a sad and
pathetic state were in Hillary a
candidate saying she can fix everything
that's wrong even though it's her team
who's been in power for the past eight
and Trump a man whose staggering lack of
worldly knowledge outside of his own
tiny bubble is somehow considered an
asset by his supporters now before I
tell you who I'm going to support and
why I want to say one more thing whoever
you choose in this election I'm actually
okay with it probably the most important
thing I've been fighting for with this
show is the ability to agree to disagree
to sit across from someone and hear
their ideas and make your own judgment
call I don't ask that you agree with my
guests or even myself in this case I
don't ask that you support who I support
nor agree with my reasons for supporting
them what I hope for not ask for is that
all of us whether you support Hillary or
Trump are able to sit across from people
who support the other person that
regardless of who someone votes for we
realize we have two candidates but one
country and most importantly that people
are able to make different choices than
you for different reasons and that
doesn't mean they're mean or evil or
even worse gross and racist I spent a
lot of time on the Rubin report talking
about the role of government it's
something so important yet in our public
discourse we rarely talk about it even
as government gets bigger and bigger
both the Democrat and Republican
conventions were perfect examples of
this at the DNC speaker after speaker
talked about how Hillary could solve all
of your problems
I guess she's had all the answers this
whole time but just forgot to tell them
to her old pal Barack every speaker
including Hilary herself said that she
has the answers and that government
under her watch can solve everything
the RNC wasn't very different though for
a series of other reasons Trump and his
speakers talked about how corrupt the
system is but their answer was that
Trump and Trump alone could fix it
immigration well only Trump has the
answers the economy lonely Trump can fix
it terrorism
only Trump can keep us safe in both
cases the answer to everything was
bigger government your decisions be it
economic or personal should be given
you by the government this concept has
been creeping on us for a long time and
now we have two candidates that think
they are the only ones who know how to
live your life even better than you do
there is simply only one way out of this
mess and I don't think it involves
propping up a broken system or burning
it down all together every election we
hear this is the most important election
in a generation but you know at this
time it actually might be true despite
everything we deserve better than this
endless battle between Republicans and
Democrats who are more concerned about
their grip on power than they are
addressing the needs of the people that
they're supposed to serve there is only
one way to take the power away from
their monopoly over our lives we must
from this election forward put both the
Democrats and the Republicans on notice
that they no longer have a stranglehold
on the political process in America the
only way we can do this is to starve
them we must starve them of our
attention of our money and our votes
their diet must begin right now for
these reasons and some others I'll be
supporting libertarian candidate Gary
Johnson for President of the United
States
I don't think Gary is the perfect man
nor the perfect candidate and I suspect
that he doesn't think he is either but
he's sure better than these other two
options as a libertarian Gary doesn't
want to tell you who you can marry and
what you can smoke he wants lower taxes
and to empower local not federal
government which in my view is always a
good thing he wants to hand the power
back to the people to control their own
lives he wants a fair resolution to our
immigration problem and he acknowledges
that radical Islam especially in the
form of Sharia law is a real threat he
wants a strong military so that we won't
have to use it not so that we can go on
military adventures and nation build his
blend of being fiscally conservative and
socially liberal is really where I think
most people are ideologically but we
just never get the chance to choose it I
do have some differences with Gary and
the libertarian party in and of itself
is a total mess but I think he best
represents the eye
deels I would want in a president
sometimes you have to stand on principle
even when you know the result will be a
short-term loss now before you guys tell
me I'm throwing my vote away let me lay
out a plan here I think that if you've
listened this far you acknowledge that
we do have a problem here well the only
way we're ever going to solve this
problem is by getting more voices heard
not less
if Gary gets to 15 percent in an average
of national polls then they have to put
him in the presidential debates why not
have at least one debate with another
voice at the absolute bare minimum we
deserve to hear one different point of
view now more than ever
I don't need a president to be my Savior
but maybe having an alternative to the
two-party stranglehold on American
politics is actually what can save us
the polling may be antiquated and many
only use landlines instead of cell
phones but I think if there was enough
public support to get Gary to 15% they
would have to put him in I don't think
Gary's even a particularly good debater
but how about once just once for the
first time since Ross Perot in 1992 we
get a third person on that debate stage
from now until the debates Gary Johnson
has my support while I acknowledge that
he will not be President nor do I agree
with him on everything I think he best
represents the ideals that I want to see
from our government and our president if
we're ever going to fix this broken mess
we must start now let's show the
Democrats and the Republicans that they
don't own us but they do owe us they owe
us the chance to hear more voices
because they damn well haven't done a
great job while they've been in charge
if Gary doesn't hit the 15 percent
threshold or does one debate and then
his support falters I'll decide what to
do at that time regardless I think that
the classical liberal and libertarian
ideals that Gary embodies more than
either of the other two candidates can
truly and should truly be the future of
American politics we need a new
generation of leaders who believe in
these ideas to wake up right
now but it just isn't going to happen by
itself so let's put the people in power
on notice and let them know that we
won't be sleeping until 2020 instead
we're going to make sure that they know
with absolute certainty that this is
their last free ride before the rest of
us are heard all right so there you go
simply by the math alone I suspect that
my choice will have more people angry at
me then either of the other two choices
could have but I hope that whether you
agree with me or whether you disagree
with me that you will respect the
rationale and the logic that I've used
to come to my decision at the end of the
day one of these people will be
president and we're still all going to
be here so let's try to be better than
them before Canada builds a wall to keep
us all out
you